hey hi hello hello what's going on
gentlemen
[Music]
yeah residency where we're gonna do a
little bit of not a hero whereas Abel
seven biohazards
not first DLC but this is one people
have been waiting for for a while you
see Chris Redfield right here with you
said it was a shotgun yeah okay
interesting
yeah so then obviously so this we also
have a so ease end which is another one
you can get this one is free this one's
free and then Zoey's end is $15 unless
you got like the variation whatever it's
called can we begin we've got work to do
I promise this I remember like when you
beat the game like our card showed up
that was like hey not even like this is
literally one of the last shots no no
ether winners has been secure because
he's alive and well considering yeah
he's next on my list looks very
different for Chris although he looks
different all the time I was actually
watching a video where they were
explaining why he looks different and
it's not like this nefarious thing it
was the fact that they for this game
they decided to face scam a lot of like
the character models okay give them a
very realistic look to go with the game
style okay and that because before they
used to make them all by hand that if
you were to take the original Chris
model and put them next to it it would
look really really weird okay and all
right Lucas is the brother he does that
like saw section with all boobity about
kind of what he was up to and you know
like you find that lab of his yeah in
the mine here which is where we are
today it kind of at the beginning it
sort of we used some of the mine assets
from the end but yeah then does go into
its on its own area okay cool you said
there's like a hub area and everything
so it's still very much like resonable
sevenish in the way they a survival
horror or what's the linear shooter
yeah it's not trying like insulting
words to put more action-oriented
yeah I mean you start off with 25
bullets right oh yeah so that's the
thing so I should be doing that when you
hit a dude they stagger
okay classic yeah that's like the resin
kind of yeah I like that one briefs
totally the action of it you can sprint
- oh you can sprint very slowly I guess
I got them - let's hope those men
haven't become a part of those
experiments I like that you're like you
eye is completely different - like a
tactical over like sense like you
actually see your hell yeah all the time
you were playing this have in VR at your
desk right I was still feel as good as
resonable seven oh yeah
which is like the best vr experience
ever it's definitely my personal
favorite and yeah it's it's really weird
going back from VR to these environments
yeah on like a regular screen there's
another John Luke in the YouTube chat
jean-luc Smith says hi hello there can
only be one yeah for those asking
hopefully the audio is better now we had
the gameplay should be good
[Music]
oh [ __ ] you can try and take that off
all you want
- adios muchachos so you have one of
those on your neck to put on my arm oh
he just did it okay Hart yeah
see I like these areas in bed like this
mask filter which is cool that's an
interesting concept
okay Metroid Prime - yeah radiation it's
got some fat gloves yeah even though
they made a more realistic like maybe
the BSAA is convinced if they weren't I
wouldn't be here working with umbrellas
gonna take some getting used to on my
part I know it must be difficult and to
tell the truth
let's just focus on the mission and
maybe we can continue this conversation
when you get back okay sure whatever
okay so they're kind of explaining some
of the backstory here you get these
notes you can kind of read we're sort of
explain what's going on kind like the
big thing at the end of the game was
like oh like umbrella what's up with
that yeah
so Chris is not working with umbrella he
is still with the BSAA
Franken five and six and they have just
asked him to come help them out okay
because at the end of the first game you
actually it looks like he's working for
umbrella right at the end of the seventh
the base game yeah that's kind of what
they seem to be implying but again he's
not working with them and and then if
you check this other one they kind of
explained what umbrellas about and
basically they're saying that they have
like repurposed themselves into a PMC
that tries to like clean up messes that
like umbrella caused gotcha although
they say that many of their staff still
was part of the original umbrella which
kind of leaves this ambiguous like are
they really in good like they're kind of
trying to set that up
okay I wonder if they'll pay that off
I've read the deal so yes I don't know
if they pay that off at the end or if
they're kind of teasing for like a
Resident Evil eight okay you said they
would with the success of this game and
they've said they want to make like
another trilogy of first-person games or
a trilogy of first-person games like
eight and nine presumably right well I
would love I would love for that yeah
seven is one my number two game of the
year after zelda personally it was uh my
number two as well yeah so this kinda
hub area and then you get these at these
different doors here that we can kind of
go in to get like say boxes here item
box you get the item box well but if you
try you can go at these at any point but
you will be restricted so I try and go
in here night vision you can't really
see anything so it's not really what I'm
trying to go in so I still think it's
pretty linear that you have to go down
okay cool
do you know do you know how how long
it's supposed to be like length yeah
likewise
no I feel like I'm about halfway through
my playthrough this is just a guess okay
so it was about you okay there yeah
there Zoe's anthem nail is that ethan
holding her know so that is Joe Baker's
apparently he is Jack's brother so he's
uncle oh yeah it's kind of what they
were I was reading about but I I really
know nothing about it
gotcha which is maybe why I'm more
curious about that one because I feel
like yeah this I had like an idea but go
you're crazy and try and track down
mucus like I have no idea what they're
trying to do with that one cool yeah I'm
curious about that as well I'm playing
through while playing through seven with
Mary Kishan are shocked to me :
a lot of people wanted to play DLCs cuz
they've also brought out a few others
like birthday party what was the one
that like made it pretty humorous with
Jack that wearing a birthday hat yeah
yeah no that was birthday party you know
there was the one where the escape room
with Marguerite that one I like that one
yeah it sucks if you like accidentally
lose it's pretty tense but yeah a bit to
trial and error for my liking
yeah it's cool I did I'm used to playing
in VR broken yeah just looking at them
nice
definitely does feel a little more
action-packed but sure so far this has
been like the most punchy
there's a punch button it's just when
there's staggered you hit the trigger Oh
gotcha okay that's probably the most
action heavy segment so far and it
stopped meeting it but other sections
get a little more interesting
there are coins nice today have our
lives yep have to unbox you can get
alright it's one of them like a steroid
syringe yeah there's a it's two
different stories I don't remember I
imagine it's just like helping
like it's the like beretta that he use
from five gears and cranks are always
useful in these games oh yeah oh there's
a crank around here somewhere
really yeah I did really really hate
Lucas like is he just playing with you
the whole time oh yeah he's he sucks
yeah in a good way
I'm glad the deal I'm hope like it says
like your mission is to capture him I
hope I just get to killing it again yeah
it's only two known I hope he
accidentally gets shot in the face by me
there there's a line later where the
girls like you got to bring him alive
you know remember to keep him alive and
Chris is like yeah sure we could we
could accidentally kill him yeah it'd be
fine do it so this is the voice actor
from resinous six and five is Chris I
think so just they actually used his
face it sounds like
it sounds like him but then it's weird
because I want to say at the end of 7 it
didn't sound it looks he looks like he's
wearing a ghillie suit yeah
I was wondering why you were not
shooting
his hands look like the Big Daddy hands
[ __ ] those do anything different those
to attack this more of a swipe and this
is alright just fun to do that that
guy's gonna blow up or something I'm
betting maybe everything's alright now
let's just really wants you to think
I'm just the bait and you fell for it
what why would you not tell me that
before
Yeah right like you would sing like you
can I told you that right away die
he couldn't have saved me I'm Chris
Redfield
look up at it
yikes yeah speaking of metro oh yeah
sorry
that's pretty gruesome
all right cool so now you can go into a
new area but I go to a new area bet you
didn't think that would backfire Lucas
now I can go down this tunnel
gube was asking is it like a mini
campaign for the DLC or is there
anything extra the whole thing is an
extra to get my yeah this takes place
after the assuming you'd have to beat
the game before you in Locker no Oh
Christian actually there was a menu that
popped up that I kind of skipped but it
didn't say something about like the end
of the game I'm not sure if it was
saying yep beat the game or if it was
just saying like hey make sure you you
do beat the game because I've got school
yeah I was gonna say there's not much
point after I'd ever Lee would not
recommend maybe in like wani minutes a
little less will try Zoey's in yeah well
I want to do this section because it's
pretty cool but then after that Wolfson
which I have not checked out yet you
pull any of the other DLCs yeah did the
escape room tribe birthday party for a
little bit what else am I missing
is there any are there any others I
liked um there's the other Lucas one
there's like a card game yeah I did that
one which was kind of fun but a little
like random for my taste
and then there was daughters which was
they kind of feel a little prequel we
actually like see the Baker family
before evelyn shows up okay cool you're
like playing a zoey and that's so that's
that's pretty as well right
no that one was part of the dance
footage i think yeah
did the band footage and the other pack
whatever it was
definitely look forward to playing these
hopefully tonight all right so these
dudes here
you just can't shoot them yeah so
grenades
is there anything else besides the story
mission to include in the DLC I guess
not not that I'm aware of it's like it
doesn't add any items to the base game I
don't think so okay how'd you know those
guys are ones you can't kill her like
the red splotches all over him yeah they
got that like release you kind of look
it does take a second to notice so this
isn't it like an extension of the mines
where you see Lucas right in the game
just keep going we're literally coming
up on that part right now because I got
lost on my first of this
yeah I'm really excited I've been really
enjoying you guys playing that yeah I
was gonna replay the game tomorrow
saying the same things there's been fun
watching Mary experience she avoided
spoiler she has no idea what happens in
the latter half of the game no that's
awesome I especially like the later
stuff with the ship super cool I was
worried it would drag on when I first
realized there's another half to the
game oh like third to the game right but
I actually think that part is very well
paced
I like that part you get that new
submachine gun alright so I just got me
some special bullets and these ones can
kill those guys in one well-placed shot
if you do it right
Burke's NL apologist I'm butchering that
and YouTube gee I was asking if end of
Zooey is including the gold edition yes
I believe this and not a hero our Gold
Edition comes with everything yeah
not a hero do you need the is it free
for anyone turret okay so [ __ ] Lucas
turrets
[Music]
I'm not going that way I guess he
grenade it or now there we go okay
houses being stupid you got syringes now
instead of uh yeah
kombucha that you pour on your wrist I
like the kombucha yeah when Mary's
playing it she actually did not see the
first animation that shows how it
reattached is oh really yeah when Jack
does it to you
and then he has you crawl toward your
hand I didn't either the first time I'm
like yeah I totally missed it it didn't
happen to me during this uh the Mia
fight but I happen to marry her that
yeah it's um
you've got three power rounds too right
yeah that games got a lot of cool little
stuff like that that's like kind of just
random yeah is the night-vision
automatic or did you it's just automatic
yeah here we Furman in the YouTube show
this is out today yeah if you own resin
evil something you can play this for
free which is pretty cool if you don't
you should and then you complain anyway
exactly saw they were selling it's kind
of weird
you could buy like coins that if you
keep in your inventory will give you
like a boost like there was like five
different coins you could buy you can
find for like 50 cents each or for like
a dollar or something you could buy all
five gonna keep going but in addition to
the coins that also automatically
unlocked in that house I wouldn't
recommend that best are you good if you
got the stole edition you don't play
that
I wouldn't recommend like I can see
myself buying it it's like say somehow I
lost my save and I was like I don't want
to play for the base game I just really
want to play the matter but if you're
playing for the very first time I would
not recommend playing that out now I
think the whole fun of that mode is how
it it's kind of like plays with your
expectations yeah this game I mean they
can come in to save rooms right the
enemies so they can at least cut through
certain doors
yeah like Jack will chase you around way
more Jack yeah I mean I like it
design-wise but I hate him yeah horror
fest was asking if there's gonna be a
review of the DLC I don't believe so
yeah why did that game allows you to
power around yeah I know not that I'm
aware of
did we give reviews for any others um I
know breath of the wild we had done some
sort of right up there might be
something about apologies I don't know
right now that that's PR reviews editor
I'm curious how expansive the zoey one
is because it is 15 bucks which is / yes
yep shoot it shoot it
what's up you're ducking those won't
detect you yeah
you think you and Mary are gonna play
any of these I really want to yeah I
feel like you get the big picture if you
play all of them definitely the escape
room escape room a daughter's I think
it's a good one no review according to
whoever's moderating we have not
reviewed and yeah and I don't think
there's not gonna be a review for this
again if we were if we weren't so busy
in the year wasn't coming to an end I
could maybe see myself doing like a hey
now that all of the DLC is out yeah
doing like a feature about it and just
like oh like how good are each DLC is
like how much did they add to the game
yeah Rainbow six thing right now yeah
yeah I really want to get into that game
2-year anniversary last week that games
like number ones right I saw something
like that just below it set 25 million
players total that have like bought the
game and stuff
the loot I know over watched it like 30
so it's not that far behind in terms of
concurrent users think concurrent I want
to say one before I saw yeah something
like that after like pub GE dota
counter-strike I think are like the big
three that make sense this team
yeah every mistakes it's a very good
blue those tag
vr mode is also live as well gently was
playing in VR before oh yeah both DLCs
are fully playable in the air punch cool
oh hello definitely a lot more enemies
oh yeah scale with the weapons what do
you believe these in like a madhouse
not really sure what that would add
though
yeah not a hero and Zoe's n purportedly
both support VR hmm so dope if you want
to just be the same then you just didn't
be our select him from the main menu
I believe yeah you just have grown the
options and turns ER oh by the way I'm
kind of like a little bit there is this
outside areas but like you should look
around and you'll find like the coins
and yeah it's definitely worth like
taking Taylor riders saying the the not
a hero TLT this short he'll be done in
30 or 45 minutes it sounds kind of about
right yeah again it's free
a coin thank you thanks but oh boy put
myself in a bad spot oh Jesus going
green fine according oh yeah
Chris it's new white variation is
extremely resilient I'm open to
suggestions ramrods so weird name for
ammo
yeah it reminds me of a Super Troopers
no I'm RAM radically called funny
characters oh man it's been forever
since I've seen City and c-26 out is
that like Lucas's logo or something you
keep seeing yeah there's um you need
like find a key and then there's all
these other rooms that have them this is
the furthest I've gotten actually so
this probably good point you maybe
switch over yeah sure well we'll try out
the other one those should go back to
the menu that this is the presumably the
bigger one it's at $15 what's being free
once you have the gold edition then you
always have it for free but you already
paid for the Gold Edition that's a
pretty good value yeah like I think the
whole game on its own is worth you know
yeah for sure how worth it and then to
get like all this extra stuff you know
it's pretty good it's not polygons
announced it with their number 5 game of
the year oh really
yeah that's good because I was worried
that be coming on February might get
overlooked that seems like it's going
well it's like a lot of people haven't
forgotten which is cool so what is the
end of Zoe a description say yeah so
this one says it's like right at the end
of the game this is says it takes a
couple weeks later Jack's brother Joe
Baker must face this danger with his
bare face you like punch people more
punching I guess put an end to his
families yeah I guess so alright let's
find out liter of Cola
yeah people talk about that resonable to
remake I'm like 80% sure that will be
announced sometime soon
it's it's happening like it can't not be
if I talked about it and I'm very
curious man if they do the one-two punch
of resin evil seven and then a good
retinol to remake be back the glory days
of resin evil which has not happened
since the first well president for was
great obviously in 2005 but it's been a
while
replaying resin alive recently I did not
like it I liked it I used to like a lot
more his co-op game but yeah I kind of
feel the same about it at the time I
loved it
looking back it's got our problems long
loading time I remember being like that
though on the base game
oh this is a huge spoiler for those who
didn't finish the base game oh yeah this
assumed you picked me aright like
everybody would you just said you're
fine the way you screaming to me
not important is saying there's one more
slot in the extra content menu for every
seven oh really and has a theory that's
all ready to remake in January which is
the anniversary of as equal to well
putting it in 70th anniversary feel like
they'd be missing out on a lot of money
in the day yeah that'd be well we're
going to do that or they would encourage
people to buy seven and then spend an
extra 20 on remake or something that'd
be the 23 makes a 20th anniversary so
they would have to announce in January
right not saying I mean that would be
ideal right that's her all right Zoe
bigger she's still breathing calling HQ
yeah what's that guy mirela
pretty polite about it - yeah I was just
saying that demo got it
that was the theories that would just be
the demo and whoa that would make more
sense
I've know all her clothes listen to me
we're here tell me what kind of help
comes
you know helicopter gunship Santa Claus
you don't know what you're talking about
you don't get it you think I don't know
who you people are
with all these monsters running around
here tell me where'd they come from
it's not what you think bottles man
don't understand I don't understand I
thought he was going for it you see the
girl back there look that damn my
brother's little girl
my niece you want to stand here family
is a righteous talk and you ain't went
to kill my family
see daddy something I can abide [ __ ]
sake she's infected she's dying and
we're both gonna [ __ ] die right now J
dead yet boy so I figure you better do
something about it before I feed you two
little friends outside okay you follow
JEP I'm super classic there's a new post
Jordana me her treatment and you [ __ ]
that up when you jumped us they probably
still waiting for us right now
where
they took it to an old shack from here
still on the mansion grounds or nearby
his house
I punched the [ __ ] deep in okay this
kind of implies he has no idea what's
going on yeah like has he just I mean he
was to spoil it he probably was not
involved with the Eveline curse poison
ivy oh she does yeah she did he just
like wasn't affected by Evelyn's the
curse or whatever from the ship right
not the curse the I've been playing I've
been playing what remains of me the
Finch yeah the infection infections he
must be far enough away where it didn't
sure that's a little weird though
because they've been like that for three
years
yeah like why just like never hung
around them yeah I mean I wouldn't
either if I was but yeah the one Carl
this is from the DLC this is a one of
the two new DLC packs today this is Zoe
Zen which is 15 dollars and then you can
also when we were just playing was not a
hero the Chris Redfield free updated I
wonder if you could actually be in the
like the swamp that was something I was
kind of hoping they would have done more
of yeah that they didn't like I wanted
to see some like you know alligators do
something what is that body bag say left
right I'll see you later do you think
you'll even not get weapons
see this is like the Jake Wesker chapter
yeah all right okay it's different
looking for that yeah okay just do to
eat grubs healed then cool a little book
punch the heads getting as many punches
as possible some good hooks Crouch
haven't sneak behind okay I'm Stella
Cathy used to be a boxer of some sort
maybe he's pretty Jack no pun intended
yeah no that's yeah yeah scary no I like
a grindhouse movie okay if they're
embracing the camp I'm on board
yeah I've played the full game and it
was scary enough to last me if they're
embracing the camp I say as you uppercut
a molded with your bare hands
yeah step on them
pick it up now man boxer effigy maybe
what's a boxer yes
boost my attack power he's for black
magic so there's Voodoo involved it's so
you are the swamp though so that's one
wish all right yeah I think my my wish
my fantasy here so he's a former boxer
who's been living off the land in the
swamps of Louisiana outside of uh figure
out the town was called Oh No what
didn't work
no he just didn't get all of it you know
punch it punch the slime
what's the danger here like if like four
of them swarm you
I guess so right
so maybe your good job Swayze er to die
I don't know I guess so he'll happily
take on enemies with his bare fists
after all they never Jam and they don't
need a really a reload yeah [ __ ] yeah
sure I don't know background check to
buy these guns
let's see tsa take these away from
oh hello there Reagan trying to like
scare you know there's what it site
Queensberry rules
I guess so sounds like an English like
street ball or thing street brawler
thing
[Music]
that's not good you're gonna need some
bigger fists whoa Jesus Christ no no no
is he upset that these things died Oh
their fish pouring out it is what is
this fish they just died well you
there's their second wish oh wait this
is back where you started
yeah oh this isn't good oh yeah
all right
why did she turn all white I don't know
it's phosphorescent wherever bales just
like [ __ ] becomes a scab won't be
enough she needs a full dose to heal
completely there's more at our base well
so tiny
way to help jean-luc watch him oh oh
he's dead check his pulse
we're leaving oh oh that's the big thing
oh sure she's in the water yeah
yep yeah that right
okay it's okay now Zoe
that thing looks familiar we're a few of
those in seven remembers that face looks
really familiar maybe was from for knows
seven when you go down into the mind
there's one of those big or when you go
into Luke's this thing I think you fight
you fight really big version yeah
they're really fat like like boomers but
you look quite like that some kind of
face let it go
Oh found it what was he not living
nearby most of his life that's what I'm
saying he's like didn't know there are
monsters in the swamp about three years
her did she like did she get a long way
before she's to come to it and that's
why they found her she just tried
skating through the swamp or something I
don't know
so there's if you brought her with you
if you picked her instead
Eveline like crystal eyes are on like
the boat right like like turned her like
frozen okay so maybe that's still what
happened to her here just a little
further
yeah someone's mentioned like Creature
from the Black Lagoon like rest evil
seven like played with saw tropes and
bright Texas Chainsaw Massacre and this
is seems to be going for like a creature
from Black Lagoon thing
what you wanted to do friends whoa I'll
bring back Jill cool well no she's in
although she's in Revelations and
whatnot maybe like Claire I meant more
as like clothes and flares or the
revelations too
I met more as like a setting Oh I'm
assuming he would be first person again
I don't know like desert ish town kind
of like outlast 2 but better okay okay
Mary if we play this just not gonna like
the alligator she did not like him five
no oh they're freaking five snow have
they done snow and Resident Evil yes six
head some of it with Jake Wesker's
campaign oh yeah Wow and Code Veronica
but that was indoors what Veronica did
have snow you're right like Pacific
Northwest like forest but that's kind of
like that might as well be a Spencer
mansion right all of your specifically
going for more forests than mansion yeah
they do like an Arctic base like the
thing although that was kind of code
Veronica but like more recent or and
more modern right like like dead space
to kind of toured with that idea but I
don't think it capitalized it 3-3 yeah
yeah one thing you cannot function all
right
you can choke out yeah get that Cajun
gumbo maybe find this like cathartic yet
you know like getting freaked out and
then I guess it just like punched some
D's in the head yeah she makes it that
far yeah she just beat Marguerite was a
very good episode yeah so what's she
doing next Lucas she yeah she's doing
all the soft stuff which is very good he
went back yeah yeah Lucas called her in
the camper so now she's going to lose
system and then she learn the mines and
then the jack main Jack fight at the
docks and then the ship mm-hmm and all
that I'm waiting to see her face when
she realized there's a whole nother like
area yeah where you play as so how are
these things still around I thought like
they were like once Evelyn died they
would like go away I guess they never
really established yeah maybe they
didn't reverse the infection just
stopped it from Brad continuing or you
killed like the patient zero was
definitely yeah she must she was the one
like throwing Scott like oh [ __ ] oh man
have you ever played uh cry primal I was
gonna say Peter Jackson's King Kong the
official game to the movie no was it
good uh at the time I really liked it it
probably doesn't hold up at all but they
gave me scant reason really interesting
it was a first-person game where you had
guns but they're like very very limited
ammo so a lot of times you'd use stealth
and you would like pick up Spears and
feel like throwing about like
velociraptors so it's actually pretty
cool nice
okay so that game probably just no okay
strength just going off the walls of
this I go for like another 10 minutes or
so right okay you want to give too much
away yeah this this DLC is not what I
expected at all
and I think gotta be setting up there
like this new umbrellas
I would imagine yeah to no one's
surprise Oh God punch it no I'm assuming
uh-oh he's punching you back
oh no Tyson versus Leonard fight a zero
found your he's best at you oh I have to
to the r2 l2 r r2 r lr
punches arm
yeah stay down mother stay down
[ __ ] that looks like the dudes
Christmas shooting in yeah he has like a
I wonder if he's an umbrella guy cuz he
looks like he has like a got helmet on
or something
oh yeah kind of
yeah it's like all the molded leaves
hated more since the game there we go
I would kick his head a few times to
make sure just wants to keep the tension
up oh my god this is like an it's like
knocking come out yeah maybe
that'd be cool whoo Oh crocodile or him
alligator sorry not crocodile
yeah we gotta say we're in his uvula
actually
a lot of us dock at all heed this boxing
effigy you never know when you'll need
to sacrifice something yeah I don't know
this sound weird yeah future a typeface
comes up you're dead yeah it's it's
wacky I guess like I don't mind them
doing something weird when they've
already done the base game a lot of DLC
but right this being $15 yeah I mean I
guess it depends how long it is and if
it's kind of like if it expands if they
keep doing more interesting stuff yeah
so far all right it's okay
and certainly not opposed to them
experimenting trying different stuff
which I feel like a lot of this deals
he's kind of been that yeah escape room
and this and even the Christoph more
action
this came out today Lauren Horner Wiley
I do like that you're in the swamp yeah
I know this is exactly what I wanted
oh [ __ ] you have any Spears
just punch the [ __ ] out of that thing oh
my god so what's a good grab I might be
just an instant death yes there's me
just sneak by them when possible then
use the Spears when that's not right
maybe oh you can craft spirits as well
scrap metal and tree branches and
neither of what you've done so far it's
good to know the crafting is involved
yeah well obviously there's chem flu
a chance game man okay all right you got
it this time no game I do not want to
lower the difficulty dying too much
thanks I hate when games ask that like I
get why they do it yeah I hate when they
do that disrespecting you
exactly
okay seems like I cannot avoid this one
but that other one I could see where he
is yeah you only have one spirit all
right yeah that one you avoided black
and I void this dude and get this spear
then much right away there's gonna be a
dude up here can you avoid him he's
moving well so is the other one the
other one I think you could have avoided
but you weren't like I think the next
one you can I think I can avoid them too
I just need to figure out Oh more Spears
or wood for this fabulous oh now you
guys right I got him
imagine one during that phase full of
teeth you look game all right now you
know you got to go that way at least all
right one more time oh this is you do
not have the ability to like this game
was not designed for melee combat yeah
it's very odd that they went with that
motif this time the spears I'm into I
think that's cool like that as that idea
is interesting stealth is interesting
punching like a machete and Spears would
be good yeah it's the punching that's
weird
oh there is two up there
okay I can probably make eat one okay
now I should be good
oh I can also try spelling it there rip
its head I love how you're like gonna
break its neck but then you just pop it
just explodes
you find themselves are fine on them
yeah it's Spears there we go
fix beer I guess they have to be
throwing alligators
Kalen so it drops a little bit when you
throw it holy [ __ ] it's really weird I
miss that oh the other one I don't
necessarily like it there's there's
exactly enough Spears for them it feels
like it's too scripted more survival
this does feel very scripted so far oh
this is back there sweet yeah cool well
that might be a good time to end it yeah
yeah well that that was Resident Evil
sevens DLCs
I like the so far like the Chris one
more than I like this one but I'm not
you know we didn't play that much of
this one so it's kind of hard to say
this one's focused on melee combat seems
a little bit odd mm-hmm but who knows
like half hour of it I sort of like the
tongue-in-cheek nature of it but it does
feel kind of weird especially going from
like how creepy the original game is
yeah yeah but anyway I'm sure you you'll
be playing these throughout the coming
days yeah not a hero and Zoey's n DLC
are both available now if you have the
gold edition for resin equal 7 they're
both available but if you don't have the
golden Gold Edition not a hero is free
anyways so and Zoe's end will be $15 US
dollars but yeah stay tuned throughout
GameSpot tomorrow at 10 a.m. we're doing
our announcing our number 8 game of the
year doing all our top tens we did 10
was near automata 9 was what remains of
Edith Finch and tomorrow we'll announce
our number 8 game of the year
and a fantastic year of games all right
really hole 7 was that January 23rd I
think mmm okay well I'll see you later
everybody thank you for joining thanks
guys
you